have you seen the gorgeous new cover
shot of Oprah if she has dropped 30
pounds you go girl
all the while telling us that she eats
bread every day really okay well she
explains and that was one of the things
that I really wanted to know about when
we got together on the set of her new TV
series now this is the thing I said I
love bread people it doesn't mean I'm
eating a loaf every day I love bread if
it's gonna be in the morning was not in
the morning today so I still have my
piece of bread left so there you have it
that's Oprah's bread rule don't eat the
whole loaf and you too can lose 30
pounds but always dropping more than
just weight she auctioned off her
wardrobe on eBay I didn't include the
nyan con skirt she wore for this 20th
season premiere and the Badgley Mischka
dress she wore on this Oh magazine cover
opening bid $0.99 I mean I've had so
many clothes most of them you know I
never wore more than once or twice I
have shoes that I barely that I
literally took downstairs put them on as
I was going out to sit in the chair and
took them off you know so I have all
these like Louboutin shoes and you paid
for as much for a shoe as you did for a
down payment on your first house it's
hard to like that shoe go yeah cleaning
out her closet Oprah has raised
thousands for her Leadership Academy but
what she's super excited about now is
her big return to acting as a series
regular on TV in the own Drummey
Greenleaf Ober is out to uncover secret
sex and sins hiding in a Memphis mega
church mmm
this time brother you go huh
the character that I play owns a blues
club and she has a bar and had a
drinking problem and all the things that
play against type for me and you know
she uses the couple of times and so is
that hard for you to actually have to
spit out I really I can just fine
I used once in Steadman said I will die
I'm not gonna stand here and listen to
that kind of language I wasn't even
talking to him
Oh symptom curse ever don't do that ever
you